From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。公共广播。国际公共广播电台。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And I'm here to tell you first today about Mr. Lewis. And I call him Mr. Lewis because, although I have asked him what his first name is and I found out, like a good journalist, I've never actually heard anybody use his first name. So it seems kind of wrong to use it here.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天首先要跟大家讲讲路易斯先生。我叫他路易斯先生是因为，虽然我问过他的名字，也知道了，但作为一个好的新闻工作者，我从来没听过有人叫他的名字。所以在这里叫他的名字感觉有点不对。
Mr. Lewis is the kind of man who has a certain effect on people. And if you visit the school where he works, James McCosh Elementary, on Chicago's South Side, you can hear what that effect is.
路易斯先生是那种对人有某种影响力的人。如果你去他工作的学校——芝加哥南区的詹姆斯·麦科什小学，你就能感受到那种影响力。
At Halloween, Mr. Lewis helps the kids convert the field house out on the school's parking lot into a two-room haunted house. It's a low-budget, handmade affair, but done so effectively that when the kindergarten, first grade, and second grade children walk in, they panic with the kind of panic that makes them drop things, that makes them scream and not stop screaming. They do not notice that the two monsters writhing on top of open graves are really just two sixth graders lying on top of barely disguised ping pong tables. They do not catch that the undead are wearing Nike cross trainers, or that sometimes, when the monsters flail about, yellow student IDs on neck chains come flopping out.
万圣节的时候，路易斯先生会帮孩子们把学校停车场里的田径房改成一个两室的鬼屋。这是一个低成本、纯手工的制作，但效果非常好，以至于幼儿园、一年级和二年级的孩子们走进去时，他们会惊慌失措，那种恐慌让他们扔掉手里的东西，让他们尖叫，而且停不下来。他们没注意到那两个在敞开的坟墓上扭动的怪物，其实只是两个躺在几乎没怎么伪装的乒乓球桌上的六年级学生。他们也没发现僵尸穿着耐克训练鞋，也没发现有时当怪物乱动时，脖子上挂着的黄色学生证会露出来。
I want your brain. I want your brain. I'm hungry.
我要你的大脑。我要你的大脑。我饿了。
This sixth grader extends her arms and sends a bunch of kids running in the other direction. The older kids play their parts with hilarious abandon, so happy they can't help grinning from ear to ear at moments when they're supposed to be scary.
这个六年级女生伸出双臂，把一群孩子吓得往反方向跑。大一点的孩子们演得极其投入，他们太开心了，以至于在应该吓人的时候，忍不住咧嘴大笑。
Come on. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Come on. They won't mess with you. Mr. Lewis is with you.
快点。[听不清楚] 快点。他们不会伤害你的。路易斯先生跟你在一起。
Into the fray, in baseball cap and yellow jacket, walks Mr. Lewis. In theory, he's the school disciplinarian, but his reign is one of love more than fear. Three or four small children grip onto each of his hands, and he walks them past the ping pong table of terror, telling them he'd never let anything bad happen to any of them. Until, suddenly, they bolt for the door.
路易斯先生戴着棒球帽，穿着黄色夹克，走进了喧闹中。理论上，他是学校的纪律主管，但他的统治更多是源于爱而非恐惧。三四个小孩紧紧抓住他的手，他带着他们走过恐怖的乒乓球桌，告诉他们他绝不会让任何坏事发生在他们身上。直到，突然间，他们冲向了门口。
My group left me. Hey, come on, Mr. Lewis is here. That group went back out that door.
我的小组丢下我了。嘿，快来，路易斯先生在这儿。那群人又回到了那扇门里。
He heads off for another group of kids to protect. The crowds thin after a while, and the girls on the ping pong table consent to an interview. One of them is holding forth on the thesis that, sure, a person could look at their outfits as striped referee jerseys, or you could choose to see them as pirate costumes. When the other girl volunteers, without any prompting, this--
他转而去保护另一群孩子。过了一会儿，人群散开了，乒乓球桌上的女孩们同意接受采访。其中一个女孩正在阐述她的观点，说当然，有人可能觉得她们的装束是裁判条纹衫，或者你也可以选择把它们看作海盗服装。当另一个女孩主动提出（无需任何提示）这一点时——
Mr. Lewis is like a father to all of us at James McCosh School. He nice and he fun to be with.
路易斯先生就像我们在詹姆斯·麦科什学校所有人的父亲。他很好，跟他在一起很有趣。
He makes us feel good. He been here for a long time. He knows most of our parents that went to this school and he just knows us.
他让我们感觉很好。他在这里待了很久了。他认识我们大多数在这所学校上过学的父母，而且他很了解我们。
When we're sad, sometimes he makes us happy and stuff.
当我们难过的时候，他有时会让我们开心之类的。
When were frowning, he make us laugh.
当我们皱着眉头时，他会让我们笑。
He funny. He like the jokester. He like to talk about people.
他很幽默。他就像个笑话大王。他喜欢谈论别人。
They tell me about their favorite activities at McCosh, the Student Leaders of Tomorrow Club, the peer leadership workshops, cheerleading. Mr. Lewis is a big part of all these. It's Mr. Lewis who made the tombstones on their ping pong table that read, "RIP, Cause of death: Gym."
她们告诉我她们在麦科什最喜欢的活动，比如“明日学生领袖俱乐部”、同伴领导力研讨会、拉拉队。路易斯先生是所有这些活动的重要组成部分。正是路易斯先生在她们的乒乓球桌上制作了墓碑，上面写着：“安息，死因：体育课。”
It's Mr. Lewis who mediates their fights. It's Mr. Lewis who really knows them.
是路易斯先生调解了她们的争吵。是路易斯先生真正了解她们。
A month after I record this tape, a child is shot after school on the parking lot just outside this building. Just a few yards from the ping pong table these girls sit on. McCosh sits in a neighborhood that has all the problems of any inner city neighborhood, and it's easy to see why the students at McCosh need someone like Mr. Lewis so badly. And it's easy to imagine these girls, decades from now, remembering Mr. Lewis, talking about him, wondering what became of him. All of us have certain figures from our childhood who assume a kind of mythic status later when we remember them. Sometimes they're people who loved us. Sometimes they're more disturbing figures.
我录下这段磁带的一个月后，一个孩子在学校停车场、就在这栋楼外被枪杀。距离这些女孩坐的乒乓球桌只有几码远。麦科什所在的社区有着任何内城社区都有的所有问题，很容易看出为什么麦科什的学生如此需要像路易斯先生这样的人。也很容易想象，几十年后，这些女孩会想起路易斯先生，谈论他，想知道他后来怎么样了。我们每个人童年里都有一些人在日后回忆起来时具有某种神话般的地位。有时他们是爱我们的人。有时他们是更令人不安的人物。
Well, today, we've devoted much of our show to a story about a man who not only had one of these legendary figures in his childhood, he decided recently he was going to track down the legend, and along the way, stumbled into this kind of odd, epic story. It is a story of the Old South, the New South, Chihuahuas, high society manners, homosexuals, and some [UNINTELLIGIBLE] changes in American journalism. Stay with us won't you?
今天，我们的大部分节目都致力于讲述一个男人的故事，他童年不仅有这样一个传奇人物，最近他还决定去追踪这个传奇，而在过程中，偶然发现了一个离奇、史诗般的故事。这是一个关于旧南方、新南方、吉娃娃犬、上流社会礼仪、同性恋者以及美国新闻业一些[听不清楚]变化的故事。请和我们待在一起，好吗？
OK, I'm going to begin things with this song about respecting those who came before you and influenced you.
好的，我打算以这首关于尊重前辈和影响过你的人的歌来开始。
[MUSIC - "RHYMIN' ON THE FUNK," DIGITAL UNDERGROUND]
[音乐 - “RHYMIN' ON THE FUNK,” DIGITAL UNDERGROUND]
Act one. So many stories about childhood are set at the first moment of adolescence, that moment when we first try to cope with the giddy, nauseating fact of what it's going to be like for us as adults. The sixth grade. This is where Jack Hitt's story and his search begin.
第一幕。关于童年的故事大多发生在青春期的那一刻，那一刻我们第一次尝试应对作为一个成年人将会是什么样子的令人眩晕、作呕的事实。六年级。这就是杰克·希特的故事和他探索开始的地方。
A quick warning before we start. Parts of this story might not be suitable for younger listeners.
开始前有一个简短的警告。这个故事的部分内容可能不适合年轻听众。
Most people have a funny little story about finding out where babies come from. I've got one.
大多数人都有一个关于发现孩子是从哪里来的有趣的短故事。我有一个。
My friend Parker Coleman told me about it. We were playing in his backyard at this particular time and place. That being 1967 in Charleston, South Carolina. Until then, I knew about the sex act only from cuss words. In my mind, it was earthy, nasty, certainly forbidden. From the air, I had picked up the idea that sex was something black folks did. Maybe whites without the right breeding. Proper people did not really have sex. A youthful impression that I've since learned is true. But when Parker told me that babies and sex were connected my sister Diane was pregnant for the first time. So I punched him in the face, hopped on my bicycle, and sped on home.
我的朋友帕克·科尔曼告诉我的。当时我们正在他家后院玩，那是1967年的南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿。在此之前，我只从脏话中知道性行为。在我脑海里，它是粗俗、下流、当然也是被禁止的。从空气中，我得出这样一个观点：性是黑人会做的事。或许是没受过良好教养的白人。正经人是不做爱的。一个年轻时的印象，我后来发现这是事实。但当帕克告诉我婴儿和性是有联系的时候，我的姐姐黛安第一次怀孕了。所以我给了他一拳，跳上自行车，飞快地回家了。
But this rather standard tale of sexual awakening occurs within a larger story. For me, a much larger story. See, in my neighborhood, we lived down the street from a British writer named Gordon Langley Hall. A slim man who preferred bow ties. I remember hearing one day that Gordon had left for a distant hospital-- Johns Hopkins-- and returned fully reconstituted as a woman who now preferred to be known as Dawn Pepita Langley Hall.
但这个关于性觉醒的标准故事发生在一个更大的故事中。对我来说，是一个大得多的故事。你看，在我的社区，我们住在一条街上，那里住着一位名叫戈登·兰利·霍尔的英国作家。一个喜欢戴领结的瘦高男人。我记得有一天听说戈登去了一家遥远的医院——约翰·霍普金斯医院——回来后完全改造成了一个女人，现在喜欢被称为道恩·佩皮塔·兰利·霍尔。
My new neighbor favored Jackie Kennedy dresses and pillbox hats. Her hair was grown out until it curled at the collar in the fashion of that time. She wore lipstick. A modest '60s bosom appeared. Not long after her operations, she announced her engagement to a handsome shrimper named John-Paul Simmons. John-Paul also worked as Dawn's butler, and John-Paul was also black.
我的新邻居喜欢穿杰奎琳·肯尼迪式的裙子，戴药盒帽。她的头发留长了，直到卷在领口，那是当时的流行款式。她涂口红。出现了并不夸张的60年代胸部。手术后不久，她宣布与一位英俊的捕虾人约翰-保罗·西蒙斯订婚。约翰-保罗也担任道恩的管家，而且约翰-保罗也是黑人。
I remember hearing that Dawn's adopted mother, the British film actress Dame Margaret Rutherford, was quoted to the effect that she didn't mind Gordon changing his sex, or Gordon marrying a man of another race, or Gordon marrying into a lower station. But she did wish that the young man was not Baptist. Such anecdotes never seemed to cease, especially after Dawn announced that she was pregnant by John-Paul. I can remember seeing her a lot during this period, walking down the street, heavy with child. Everyone said it was a pillow under her dress. The town began to freak, and properly did so when she returned from the secret birthing-- it was in England-- with a beautiful mulatto baby.
我记得听说道恩的养母，英国电影女演员玛格丽特·卢瑟福女爵被引用说，她不介意戈登改变性别，也不介意戈登嫁给另一个种族的人，或者戈登嫁给社会地位较低的人。但她确实希望那个年轻人不是浸信会教徒。这类轶事似乎层出不穷，尤其是在道恩宣布她怀上了约翰-保罗的孩子之后。我记得在那段时期经常见到她，走在街上，身怀六甲。每个人都说那是她裙子底下的枕头。小镇开始抓狂，当她从秘密分娩——那是在英国——带着一个美丽的混血婴儿回来时，小镇确实抓狂了。
Well, that was the last straw for Charleston. Unseen pressures were applied and one day I heard that the house was sold. Almost overnight Dawn disappeared, and almost as quickly, became a bizarre Gothic yarn I told to stunned audiences.
好吧，那是压垮查尔斯顿的最后一根稻草。施加了看不见的压力，有一天我听说那栋房子卖了。几乎是一夜之间，道恩消失了，也几乎同样快地变成了一个我讲给震惊的听众听的离奇哥特故事。
But over the years, even I no longer believed the story and just quit telling it. Eventually, one ceased to hear about Dawn at all.
但多年来，连我自己都不再相信这个故事，就不再说了。最终，人们不再听说关于道恩的任何消息。
Now around the time she announced her marriage, I remember being sent to my brother's room. Bobby, who was 17, was given the task of setting me straight on the facts of life. Given what was going on down the street, Bobby had a lot of ground to cover.
大约在她宣布结婚的时候，我记得我被叫到我哥哥的房间。17岁的博比被委以重任，要给我讲清楚生活的真相。鉴于街上发生的事情，博比有很多内容要讲。
I remember he confirmed Parker Coleman's story. Then by way of bridging his material to Dawn, he told me what homosexuals were and what they did. Then he told me about transsexuals with complete details on cutting up the penis and surgically fashioning a vagina. I was 10.
我记得他证实了帕克·科尔曼的故事。然后为了把他的内容引向道恩，他告诉了我什么是同性恋者，他们做什么。然后他非常详细地告诉了我关于变性人的事，包括切除阴茎和通过手术制造阴道。那时我10岁。
Part of what I remember of that era is that the media arrived every time there was a new outrage in the ongoing Dawn saga and that the story went national many times over the next few years. I can remember sneaking down to that house, trying to catch a peep of anything through the wrought iron gates. Dawn. She became my own Boo Radley, a sexual parable, a Zen koan of the bizarre. For me, the mystery of sex still has an overwrought tabloid grandeur to it.
我记得那个时代的其中一部分是，每当道恩的故事中出现新的丑闻，媒体就会蜂拥而至，而且这个故事在接下来的几年里多次成为全国性新闻。我记得我偷偷溜到那栋房子，试图通过锻铁大门看一眼什么东西。道恩。她成了我自己的布·拉德利，一个性的寓言，一个离奇的禅宗公案。对我来说，性的神秘感仍然带有一种夸张的小报壮丽感。
Almost three decades have passed, and like I said, I've come to doubt the entire Dawn epic cycle. I knew there had to be some truth to it, but I also know that childhood memory is a net, snagging and shaping every little fact and rumor into the stuff of symbolic language. I assume that there is a little nugget of truth in Dawn, and I wanted to find out what it was. So I ran back to mom. She has lived in Charleston all her life.
近三十年过去了，就像我说的，我开始怀疑整个道恩史诗周期。我知道它一定有某种真实成分，但我也知道童年记忆是一张网，捕捉并塑造每一个小事实和谣言，将其变成象征性语言的材料。我假设道恩的故事里有一点点真实的核心，我想找出那是什么。所以我跑回去找妈妈。她一生都住在查尔斯顿。
We poured some iced tea one afternoon and sat at her dining room table.
一天下午，我们倒了一些冰茶，坐在她的餐桌旁。
When Gordon was still a guy--
当戈登还是个男人时——
Can you say that?
你能说这个吗？
Yeah, I can say that.
嗯，我可以这样说。
OK.
好的。
That's my mom whispering. You can't really hear her. What's she saying is, "Can you say that on the radio?" Here, listen again.
那是我的妈妈在低语。你听不清楚。她说的是：“你能在广播里说这个吗？”来，再听一遍。
When Gordon was still a guy--
当戈登还是个男人时——
Can you say that?
你能说这个吗？
Yeah, I can say that. When Gordon was still a guy--
嗯，我可以这样说。当戈登还是个男人时——
You see, good Charlestonians do not discuss private affairs openly. If at all, we discuss them sotto voce, sometimes literally in a whisper. This impulse is compounded by the fact that Dawn's story is so over the top that my mom can't really talk about it, even still. Dawn can not be considered seriously. Dawn can not even be considered. The very question is preposterous.
你看，好的查尔斯顿人不会公开讨论私人事务。如果非要讨论，我们也是低声讨论，有时甚至是字面意义上的耳语。这种冲动是因为道恩的故事太夸张了，以至于我妈妈即使到现在也无法真正谈论它。道恩不能被认真对待。道恩甚至不能被讨论。这个问题本身就荒谬可笑。
No, I never really had anything to do with him at all.
不，我从来没跟他有什么往来。
We never had him over for dinner.
我们从没请他吃过饭。
Are you kidding? I didn't even hardly speak to him. My goodness, Jack.
你开什么玩笑？我几乎都没跟他说过话。天哪，杰克。
I'm sorry, Mom.
对不起，妈妈。
I can't get Mom to really remember much about Dawn. As we talk, she whispered to me a number of times that she really has nothing to say, would rather not talk about it, and would prefer I turn off the tape recorder. So I tried to change the subject to the neighborhood we shared with Dawn because it's part of the story.
我无法让妈妈真正记住关于道恩的太多事情。当我们谈话时，她好几次低声对我说，她真的没什么可说的，宁愿不谈论它，并希望我关掉录音机。所以我试着转换话题，谈谈我们和道恩共享的那个社区，因为它是故事的一部分。
In the mid '60s, Daddy had moved the family out of the historic part of downtown Charleston, a white neighborhood, into an uptown slum called Ansonborough, predominately black. The few whites in the area were mainly homosexuals who had moved there, as we did, to buy an antebellum home for cheap and fix it up.
60年代中期，爸爸把全家从查尔斯顿市中心的历史区（一个白人社区）搬到了一个叫安森伯勒的上城贫民窟，那里主要是黑人。该地区的少数白人主要是同性恋者，他们像我们一样搬到那里，为了低价买下一栋战前的房子并进行修缮。
In this context, Gordon was just one of what was known as the "confirmed bachelors" in the 'hood.
在这种背景下，戈登只是社区里所谓的“单身汉”之一。
He seemed to be very [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. He'd written a couple of things that, whether anybody read them or not, I don't know. But they were written up nicely in the papers. And the people mostly that entertained him were-- he did socialize a little bit with some writers and all. And a few of the dowagers, so to speak, really had him for entertainment value, and they liked him. And then of course, later when they found out about him, they didn't. They cut him off fast.
他似乎很[听不清楚]。他写过几样东西，不管有没有人读，我不知道。但它们在报纸上写得很好。招待他的人大部分是——他确实和一些作家什么的有一点社交。有一些贵妇人，可以说，确实把他当作娱乐对象，她们喜欢他。当然，后来当她们发现他的事情时，她们就不了。她们很快就跟他断绝了往来。
But he was a kind of a semi-sensation for a while around Charleston.
但他曾在查尔斯顿风靡一时。
Now what made him sensational? Was it that he was a writer, or that he was flamboyant, or what?
那么是什么让他风靡一时？是因为他是作家，还是因为他浮夸，还是什么？
No, he was very different. And then he had--
不，他非常与众不同。而且他有——
I mean, did people understand that he was possibly a homosexual?
我是说，人们是否理解他可能是一个同性恋者？
No. No, I don't think they-- this was the beginning of a lot of people like that coming to Charleston. And a lot of them have added a lot to Charleston.
不。不，我不认为他们——这正是许多这样的人来到查尔斯顿的开始。而且他们中的很多人为查尔斯顿增色不少。
After 45 minutes of tea drinking and considering the cultural contributions of homosexuals, mom did remember one story. It was not about race, or class, or genitals, or sex. But like every Dawn account, it was Gothic, almost supernatural. It concerned Dawn's restored mansion.
在喝了45分钟茶并考虑了同性恋者的文化贡献后，妈妈确实想起了一个故事。那不是关于种族、阶级、生殖器或性的。但像每一个关于道恩的叙述一样，它是哥特式的，几乎是超自然的。它关于道恩修缮后的豪宅。
When a friend of your sister's bought the house it was so horrible inside.
当你姐姐的一个朋友买下那栋房子时，里面太可怕了。
Like what?
比如什么？
Just pretty bad.
相当糟糕。
In what way?
怎么个糟糕法？
All of the floors had to be re-sanded and everything. It had animals in there. They had kept a pig in there. That type of thing. Just filthy. Just filthy.
所有的地板都得重新打磨之类的。里面养了动物。他们在那儿养了一头猪。那种事情。简直肮脏。简直肮脏。
He kept a pig in there?
他在里面养了一头猪？
Well, he kept some kind of animals. Yeah, there was a pig in there. And there was all kind of animals. Just everything had to be sanded and scoured, and all like that.
嗯，他养了某种动物。是的，里面有一头猪。还有各种各样的动物。每样东西都必须打磨和擦洗，诸如此类。
That's right, a pig. See, that's how Dawn's stories kind of go. Anyway, Mom did suddenly recall one important detail of Dawn the person.
没错，一头猪。你看，道恩的故事通常就是这样。总之，妈妈突然想起道恩这个人的一个重要细节。
He had piercing brown eyes. I remember, he would look at you, and it would kind of almost be scary, I thought.
他有一双深邃的棕色眼睛。我记得，他会盯着你看，那简直有点吓人，我觉得。
For you Yankees who have never heard a pure Charleston accent, that's piercing brown eyes. I remember their haunting quality too. And as I talked to people in town, both on and off the radio, it was all they remembered of Dawn, the person.
对于那些从没听过纯正查尔斯顿口音的北方佬，那是“深邃的棕色眼睛”。我也记得它们那种挥之不去的特质。当我无论在广播里还是广播外与城里的人交谈时，这就是他们对道恩这个人的唯一记忆。
Otherwise, the tales sounded like an emerging mythology. Cloven-hooved animals, Medusa-like stare. Dawn, a Charleston legend.
除此之外，这些故事听起来就像是一段正在形成的传说。蹄状的动物，美杜莎般的凝视。道恩，一个查尔斯顿的传说。
For most of my adult life, especially as I became a reporter, I have also seen the story cycle as a parable of modern journalism, the last stand of an old fashioned media that struggled not to let scandalous claims dictate the headlines.
在我成年后的大部分时间里，尤其是当我成为一名记者后，我也将这个故事周期视为现代新闻业的寓言，这是一个旧式媒体试图不让丑闻式的说法左右头条新闻的最后防线。
In my own personal history, Dawn was the first Lorena Bobbitt, Tonya Harding, or Joey Buttafuoco. I only mention this because my father was the editor of the Afternoon Daily in Charleston, and he never ran a single article about the Dawn scandal. He thought it was all a publicity stunt to sell Gordon's treacly books that had titles like Golden Boats to Burma.
在我个人的历史中，道恩是第一个洛蕾娜·博比特、托尼亚·哈丁或乔伊·巴塔福科。我提这个是因为我父亲是查尔斯顿《下午日报》的编辑，他从未刊登过任何关于道恩丑闻的文章。他认为这一切都是为了推销戈登那些书名如《金船去缅甸》般感伤的书而进行的炒作。
My father died before the wedding. But even afterwards, the local coverage was subdued. Dawn's wedding announcement appeared as a filler on the obituary page.
我父亲在婚礼前就去世了。但即便是在那之后，当地的报道也很克制。道恩的结婚公告作为讣告页的填充物出现。
Meanwhile, this was a national story in the tabloids and on television. Newsweek splashed a full page spread of Dawn's wedding, complete with controversial photos of the interracial couple. And the New York Daily News ran some classic headlines, "Troth is Stranger Than Fiction," said their first story on the nuptials.
与此同时，这是一个全国性的故事，出现在小报和电视上。《新闻周刊》用整版篇幅报道了道恩的婚礼，配上了这对跨种族夫妇备受争议的照片。《纽约每日新闻》刊登了一些经典标题，比如他们关于婚礼的第一篇报道称“誓言比小说更离奇”。
In another edition, there is a first person account of the wedding. Here, let me read it. "Dawn Pepita Hall, a British born male before a sex change operation last October, changed her name tonight, marrying her former butler, a negro. Wearing a full-length white gown with a 12 foot train, the thin, brown-haired Miss Hall entered the wedding room in her restored Charleston mansion to the strains of "The Battle Hymn of the Republic" and was married to John-Paul Simmons, 30. 25 guests and a handful of newsmen witnessed the 20-minute ceremony, performed by the Reverend William Singleton, a negro who appeared ill at ease."
在另一版中，有一篇关于婚礼的第一人称叙述。来，让我读一下。“道恩·佩皮塔·霍尔，去年10月变性手术前的英国出生男性，今晚改了名字，嫁给了她以前的管家，一个黑人。穿着一件带12英尺拖尾的全长白色礼服，瘦弱、棕色头发的霍尔小姐在《共和国战歌》的乐曲声中步入她修缮后的查尔斯顿豪宅内的婚礼现场，嫁给了30岁的约翰-保罗·西蒙斯。25名宾客和几名新闻记者见证了这场20分钟的仪式，仪式由牧师威廉·辛格尔顿主持，他是个看起来很不自在的黑人。”
That might be my favorite sentence of the Dawn coverage, although this one, also from the same tabloid, is close. Quote, "Miss Hall said the news had not been received so joyfully in Charleston's top society, in which Gordon Langley Hall, the man, once moved freely."
那可能是我最喜欢的一段关于道恩报道中的句子，尽管这一句，也来自同一份小报，也很接近。引用，“霍尔小姐说，这个消息在查尔斯顿的上流社会并没有得到那么欢快的接收，戈登·兰利·霍尔，那个男人，曾经在那里自由出入。”
The writer of these sentences, it turns out, is an old family friend, Jack Leland. He worked for my dad as a writer on the paper. But given the local embargo, and being no fool, Jack started stringing for the Daily News. Jack is now the town elder in Charleston, a famous storyteller and authority. Everyone knows him, and anyone who writes about Charleston must obtain an audience with Jack. When V. S. Naipaul wrote his book, A Turn in the South , the entire Charleston chapter is basically a long dinner and late afternoon constitutional with Jack Leland.
写下这些句子的作者，原来是我们的一位老朋友，杰克·利兰。他曾作为作家在我父亲的报社工作。但考虑到当地的禁令，又不是傻瓜，杰克开始为《每日新闻》供稿。杰克现在是查尔斯顿的镇长、著名的讲故事的人和权威。每个人都认识他，任何写查尔斯顿的人都必须获得杰克的接见。当V.S.奈保尔写他的书《南方之行》时，整个查尔斯顿那一章基本上就是与杰克·利兰的一顿漫长的晚餐和深夜漫步。
These days, Jack has trouble walking. He is living with his daughter, [? Chivas, ?] way outside of town at a spit of land in the woods. [? Chivas' ?] new house, provided by post hurricane Hugo funds, has stunning views past a yard full of oaks, the obligatory Spanish moss snagging every branch, and then a small creek and a vista of brown green marsh grass out to the horizon. Jack spends his morning with an attendant in the quiet of the house taking in the view. So I stopped by. He remembered Gordon.
这些日子，杰克走路很困难。他和他的女儿[？希瓦斯？]住在城外很远的地方，在树林里的一块陆地上。[？希瓦斯？]的新房子由飓风雨果后的资金提供，有一片树林满是橡树、每根树枝上都挂着必要的西班牙苔藓，然后是一条小溪，视野里是延伸到地平线的棕绿色沼泽草。杰克每天早上和一名护理人员在安静的房子里欣赏美景。所以我顺道拜访了他。他记得戈登。
He came down there with a very good recommendation. He knew the proper people in New York, and he had written a book, and he had an English accent. And that was enough to make him the darling of Charleston society for a while. Until they found out he was a homosexual, then they dropped him. Because at that time, being a homosexual wasn't exactly proper in Charleston. At that time.
他带着很好的推荐来到这里。他认识纽约的正经人，写过一本书，还有一口英国口音。这足以让他成为查尔斯顿社交圈一段时间的宠儿。直到他们发现他是个同性恋，然后他们就抛弃了他。因为在那个时候，做同性恋在查尔斯顿并不完全正派。在那个时候。
I forgot to ask Jack when it became proper to be a homosexual in Charleston. Anyway, Jack is the only person I know who attended the famous wedding of Dawn Langley Hall and John-Paul Simmons, at the house on 56 Society Street.
我忘了问杰克是什么时候在查尔斯顿做同性恋变得正派了。总之，杰克是我认识的唯一一个参加过在协会街56号的房子里举行的道恩·兰利·霍尔和约翰-保罗·西蒙斯著名婚礼的人。
It was a farce. They were all gathered in the living room, the big living room. There was a group of people in there, and the bride wasn't present. They had a negro minister who couldn't read the prayer book properly. And they had a makeshift altar in front of the fireplace. There was a TV station there. And when the bridal party came down the stairs to the tune of "The Battle Hymn of the Republic," which I thought was the beginning of a farce at the moment.
那是一场闹剧。他们都聚集在客厅里，大客厅。里面有一群人，新娘没在场。他们有一个黑人牧师，甚至不能正确地朗读祈祷书。他们在壁炉前设了一个临时的祭坛。那里有一个电视台。当新娘一行随着《共和国战歌》的曲调从楼梯上下来时，我认为那一刻是一场闹剧的开始。
They came into the living room and he discovered that he would have his back to the camera. So he made the preacher turn around and put his back to the camera and let him face the audience.
他们来到客厅，他发现自己将背对着摄像机。于是他让牧师转过身，背对摄像机，面向观众。
There were two little babies toting the train. He had a regular wedding gown on, with a mantilla on his head over a wig. And the train was attached to the mantilla in some way and those two little ones, when they went to swing around, were swinging in a wide circle, and almost pulled his wig off.
有两个小婴儿负责托着婚纱长裙。他穿着一件正规的婚纱，头上戴着一顶假发，上面还盖着一块蕾丝头纱。长裙以某种方式系在头纱上，那两个小孩在转身的时候转了一个大圈，差点把他的假发拽下来。
And what happened after the vows were exchanged? Were you there for the reception?
交换誓言之后发生了什么？你参加婚宴了吗？
It was a wang bang affair with a lot of people, all black. Very much all black. There were just a few whites.
那是一场盛大的婚礼，来了很多人，几乎全是黑人。真的，几乎全是黑人。只有极少数白人。
Who was there?
都有谁在场？
Well, I can't remember the names now. But there were people who worked in the furniture business. And that business generally attracted homosexuals.
嗯，我现在记不清名字了。但有一些从事家具行业的人。那个行业通常吸引同性恋者。
The furniture business attracted homosexuals?
家具行业吸引同性恋者？
In Charleston it did, the antique business.
在查尔斯顿确实如此，古董行业也是。
Oh, right.
哦，对。
It turns out Jack was right about homosexuals and antiques. In the 1960s, there was a well known, though never admitted, gay aristocracy in Charleston, centered in part on antiques, and located in my neighborhood.
事实证明，杰克关于同性恋和古董的看法是对的。在20世纪60年代，查尔斯顿有一个众所周知但从未公开承认的同性恋贵族圈子，他们部分以古董为中心，就住在我的社区。
One of those men was [? Jay Romp, ?] who's still a family friend. We spent a lot of time together when I was little. I can remember as a boy climbing through a dense garden down the street, up a high wall to get onto his balcony. To hang around and crack jokes and gossip with Jay and his hilarious friends.
其中一个人是杰伊·罗普（音译），他至今仍是我们家的朋友。我小时候我们花了很多时间在一起。我还记得小时候，我会爬过街对面茂密的花园，翻过高高的围墙爬上他的阳台。去和杰伊以及他那些风趣的朋友们闲逛、开玩笑、聊八卦。
I don't think I ever walked through his front door. I thought maybe Jay would remember Dawn, maybe even Gordon, and who they were. So I called him up and one warm afternoon, he picked me up in his convertible.
我想我从没走过他的正门。我心想杰伊或许还记得道恩，甚至记得戈登，以及他们是谁。于是我给他打了电话，在一个温暖的下午，他开着敞篷车来接我。
As is still the custom in Charleston, despite all the moral outrage elsewhere, we fixed ourselves what are known locally as travelers. Drinks, that in case the vice squad is listening, we'll describe as [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. And we drove uptown to Ansonborough.
正如查尔斯顿的老规矩一样，尽管外面有各种道德指责，我们还是按当地习惯准备了所谓的“随行酒”。那是些什么酒呢，以防警察监听，我们姑且描述为（难以辨认）。然后我们开车去安森伯勒区。
Now that's where you lived. That's where you lived. I remember I used to climb in the second story window.
你就是住在那儿。你住在那儿。我记得我以前常从二楼窗户爬进去。
We've got to go see that gate. We've got to see the wall, because the other thing is that wall-- Jack, when I think about it, that wall was like 18 feet high. There's monkey blood in you, young'un. There has got to be to scale those walls, because the banana trees were like 20 feet tall. We took the house-- rather I took it, Edward took it just because he trusted me. And I said, it's like the dawn of creations of [? Astier's ?] garden. You'll only know that when you hit the back. But as I say, to scale that wall would have been a feat, I think. Even for nine years old, you were then?
我们一定要去看看那扇大门。我们得看看那堵墙，因为另一件事是那堵墙——杰克，回想起来，那堵墙有18英尺高。你这小家伙身上有猴子血统吧。翻过那些墙肯定得有本事，因为香蕉树都有20英尺高。我们当时接手了那栋房子——或者说是我接手的，爱德华接手是因为他信任我。我说，这就像阿斯蒂尔花园（音译）创世纪的黎明。只有走到后面你才会知道。但就像我说的，翻过那堵墙本身就是个壮举。即使那是你九岁的时候？
I think this is how starved I was for culture, Jay.
我想这就是我对文化有多么渴望，杰伊。
It has been so long since both of us were in this part of town that we had trouble locating Dawn's infamous house.
我们两个在这个城区待的时间太长了，以至于我们费了很大劲才找到道恩那栋臭名昭著的房子。
Which one was her house?
哪一栋是她的房子？
This one.
这一栋。
Was it this one?
是这栋吗？
Wait a minute.
等一下。
No, wait a minute. It's this one up here. It's up here.
不，等一下。是上面那栋。在那儿。
Two that look alike, yeah. That's the famous porch.
两栋长得挺像，对。那就是著名的门廊。
There it is.
就在那儿。
The famous porch.
著名的门廊。
What's famous about the porch?
这个门廊有什么著名的？
Well, you know the wedding was held, and the music was done by, I believe at that point they called it Victrola. A well known orchestra, of course, who played-- who knows? A combination of rap, Japanese, pipe, avant garde music and Charleston spirituals. I have no earthly idea. But anyway, it was on that porch on the other side of the garden. And that's where the main wedding was.
嗯，你知道婚礼是在那儿举行的，当时的音乐是由——我相信那时他们管它叫“胜利号”（Victrola）。当然，那是一个很有名的管弦乐队，他们演奏——谁知道呢？融合了说唱、日语、风笛、先锋派音乐和查尔斯顿灵歌。我根本不知道。但不管怎样，它就在花园另一侧的那个门廊上。那是主要婚礼举行的地方。
You know, when I called Jay, I didn't say, I'm doing a story about gay culture. I said, I'm doing a story about my coming of age in Ansonborough and Dawn.
你知道吗，我给杰伊打电话时，我没说“我正在写一篇关于同性恋文化的报道”。我说的是“我正在写一篇关于我在安森伯勒和道恩的成长经历的故事”。
The truth is, I've known Jay all my life, and we have never discussed his sexual orientation, because people in Charleston see no reason to discuss such things. As with my mom, so with me. And even with Jay.
事实上，我认识杰伊一辈子了，我们从来没有讨论过他的性取向，因为查尔斯顿人觉得没必要讨论这些事。正如我妈的态度一样，我也是如此。甚至对杰伊也一样。
What would it have been like for-- well, first of all, let me ask you this. Are you gay? Because I've never asked you that.
那会是什么感觉——嗯，首先，让我问你这个。你是同性恋吗？因为我从来没问过你。
Well, let's put it as Tennessee Williams said. I have covered the waterfront. And the other thing is--
嗯，咱们就用田纳西·威廉姆斯的话来说吧。我阅人无数。还有一点就是——
Such a great Charleston answer. Indirect, funny, no bad words. Still, Jay can be wicked, as when he told me about calling his old roommate from those days to help jar his memory.
这真是个非常“查尔斯顿式”的回答。含蓄、风趣、没有脏话。不过，杰伊有时候很调皮，就像他告诉我，他打电话给当年住在一起的室友来帮他回忆时说的那样。
When I was talking to Eddie I said to him, Jack is doing a story on Ansonborough, part of his sexual awakening. I didn't sleep with Jack, did I?
我和埃迪聊天时对他说，杰克正在写一篇关于安森伯勒的文章，关于他性觉醒的一部分。我当时没跟杰克睡过吧？
My mother's going to love that part of the interview.
我妈会喜欢采访里的这一段的。
As Jay and I drove around reminiscing, he told me his version of Gordon's fall from grace. Now, all my life I had heard that Gordon was ostracized right after the sex change operation became public. But Jack Leland had said the city shunned him even before that, when they learned he was homosexual. Now Jay remembers a slightly more extravagant occasion.
当杰伊和我开车绕来绕去回忆往事时，他告诉了我他所知的戈登失宠的版本。我这辈子一直听说戈登是在变性手术公开后才被排挤的。但杰克·利兰曾说，早在甚至得知他是同性恋时，城市就已经避之唯恐不及了。现在杰伊记得一个稍微更铺张的场合。
She had her dogs make their debut in Charleston, including wearing real cultured pearls.
她让她的狗在查尔斯顿首次亮相，甚至戴上了真正的养殖珍珠。
Get out of here. I don't remember this story. What's this story? When was this?
别开玩笑了。我不记得这个故事了。这是什么故事？是什么时候发生的？
That was even in the paper, please. And this was when he was still Gordon Langley.
这甚至都登报了，真的。那时他还是戈登·兰利。
So this is prior to the sex change and prior to the marrying--
所以这是在变性之前，也是在结婚之前——
So he was breaking rules even back when.
所以他当时就在打破常规了。
This is what I mean about Dawn. Everyone has a story. And here it is 30 years after her sex change operation and I am still hearing fresh, new ones. And yet, they all fit into the unique genre that is Dawn Langley Hall.
这就是我提到道恩的原因。每个人都有一个故事。距离她的变性手术已经过去30年了，我还在听到新鲜的、新的故事。然而，它们都符合道恩·兰利·霍尔这个独特的体裁。
Later during my stay, I was at a cocktail party with many Charlestonians. The dog story would come up from time to time and always slightly different. In one account I heard it was a wedding. In another it was Great Danes that were given a debutante party. But as I moved among the different subcultures of Charleston, these stories provided me with another insight into Dawn. She was a scandal not only for straight Charlestonians, but for the gay aristocracy as well, two groups who were often hard to distinguish in those days.
后来在我逗留期间，我和许多查尔斯顿人参加了一个鸡尾酒会。那段关于狗的故事时常被提起，而且每次都有些微不同。在一个版本中，我听说那是一场婚礼。在另一个版本中，那是给大丹犬举办的社交名流派对。但当我在查尔斯顿的不同亚文化圈中穿梭时，这些故事让我对道恩有了另一种洞察。她不仅对异性恋的查尔斯顿人来说是一桩丑闻，对同性恋贵族圈来说也是，这两个群体在当时往往很难区分。
The whole thing was you had to be married. So this group I'm talking about who were gay were all married men. Most of them, in fact, I would say at this point all of them-- I can't think of one offhand who did not have children.
整件事的关键是你必须结婚。所以我说的这个同性恋群体都是已婚男人。事实上，我想说在这一点上他们所有人——我一时想不出有谁是没有孩子的。
I would know these children?
我认识这些孩子吗？
We went to school with them.
我们和他们一起上过学。
I would know all these children, wouldn't I?
我会认识所有这些孩子，对吧？
You'd know all these children. Actually, Charleston could have almost handled the change, even the black husband to some extent, all of that in time. It would eventually, I think, have been almost accepted to some extent, like you say.
你会认识所有这些孩子。其实，查尔斯顿本来几乎是可以接受这种改变的，甚至在某种程度上也能接受黑人丈夫，这一切假以时日的话。我认为，最终，这在某种程度上几乎会被接受，就像你说的。
Are you talking about among the gay culture, or among the culture--
你是指在同性恋文化圈内，还是指在……文化中——
I'm talking about this gay culture who was basically straight. This married gay culture with children. And I do believe that if it had not been for the publicity, that at some point, probably, yeah. They would have been accepted.
我指的是这种本质上是异性恋的同性恋文化。这种有孩子的已婚同性恋文化。而且我确实相信，如果不是因为媒体曝光，在某种程度上，大概是的。他们本是可以被接受的。
But there was publicity. And the gay culture of Charleston felt exposed. The way Jay described it, Dawn represented a kind of Gone with the Wind , a closing of an era for his crowd. Their private, serene Charleston life, married, but gay, with children, would soon end in a noisy media circus of Dawn Langley Hall. So the homosexual culture really didn't know Dawn either. Although Jay had one encounter with Dawn, sort of like my mom's.
但确实有媒体曝光了。查尔斯顿的同性恋文化感到被暴露了。按照杰伊的描述，道恩代表了一种《乱世佳人》式的时代终结。他们那种隐秘、宁静的查尔斯顿生活——已婚但同性恋，还有孩子——很快就在道恩·兰利·霍尔那嘈杂的媒体马戏团中结束了。所以同性恋文化圈其实也不了解道恩。尽管杰伊和道恩有过一次邂逅，有点像我妈的那次。
It was a misty evening when he and a friend had passed her on the street. She shot them an evil look from those piercing brown eyes.
那是一个雾蒙蒙的夜晚，他和朋友在街上经过她身边。她用那双锐利的棕色眼睛恶狠狠地瞪了他们一眼。
Very foggy night. I mean, the whole thing was perfect for the scene. And we had passed Dawn walking the dogs. And had gone two or three steps. And suddenly, all the lights in Ansonborough went off at one time. I mean, street lights, house lights, the whole thing. And we hauled butt then to my house. I think they were off about 30 or 40 minutes. We talked the other day. We didn't know because we got candles and things and barricaded the door. But again, Dawn was supposed to have some sort of powers. That was the other thing.
雾特别浓的夜晚。我的意思是，整件事非常符合那种场景。我们经过正在遛狗的道恩。刚走了两三步，突然，安森伯勒所有的灯同时熄灭了。我是说路灯、房屋照明，全部熄灭。然后我们拔腿跑回我家。我想停电大概持续了30到40分钟。我们前几天还聊到这件事。我们当时不知道发生了什么，因为我们找了蜡烛之类的东西，还把门堵住了。但又有人说，道恩似乎有什么特殊力量。那是另一回事。
Now wasn't part of the story that the voodoo that she might have had was learned from her husband, right?
难道故事的一部分不是说她可能掌握的巫术是从她丈夫那里学来的吗？
Well, that was the other story then. Naturally, by marrying black, you would have had more, I guess, background with it then, or someone who could really teach you what to do.
嗯，那是当时的另一个说法。自然地，通过嫁给黑人，我想你会更有相关的背景，或者有人能真正教你该怎么做。
A few days after riding with Jay, my brother-in-law and I spent an afternoon, as we often do, hanging out at bookstores. At one called [? Katie ?] [? and ?] [? Daughter, ?] I turned, look onto a shelf, and there was Dawn Langley Hall, just as I remembered her.
和杰伊开车兜风几天后，我和妹夫花了一个下午，像往常一样在书店闲逛。在一家叫“凯蒂和女儿”的书店里，我转头看向书架，道恩·兰利·霍尔就在那里，和我记忆中的一模一样。
It was a wedding picture with the cheerful, young John-Paul Simmons at her side. The title could not have been more apt, Dawn, A Charleston Legend.
那是一张结婚照，旁边是欢快的年轻小伙约翰-保罗·西蒙斯。书名再贴切不过了：《道恩，一段查尔斯顿的传奇》。
She had written it herself and it had just come out. I picked up the book and stared at it incomprehensibly. I hadn't seen her in 30 years.
那是她自己写的，刚刚出版。我拿起书，不可思议地盯着它看。我已经30年没见过她了。
That person used to live here, said the clerk. I know people who knew her.
店员说：“那个人以前住在这儿。我认识了解她的人。”
I just bought my copy and went home.
我买了一本，然后回家了。
The writing in this book is sugary, full of romantic images, wistful goodbyes, big Fabio-like gestures. Dawn drops names and Florida aphorisms with abandon. The first line of the book reads, "My good friend, novelist Rita Mae Brown so aptly said, 'If you take a man to Charleston and in three days he does not propose, throw him in the Crape myrtle.'"
书里的文字很甜腻，充满了浪漫的意象、忧郁的告别和夸张的姿态。道恩随意地抛出名人名字和佛罗里达格言。书的第一行写着：“我的好朋友，小说家丽塔·梅·布朗曾精辟地说过：‘如果你带一个男人去查尔斯顿，如果三天内他还没向你求婚，就把他扔进紫薇花丛里。’”
But my biggest discovery while reading the book was the author's bio. I learned that Dawn and I remain neighbors.
但我读这本书时最大的发现是作者简介。我了解到道恩和我在现在依然是邻居。
She lives in Hudson, New York, not far down the road from where I now live. So I called her up. I didn't tell her immediately I was a Charlestonian, just that I would like to interview her for the radio. She said she'd be delighted.
她住在纽约州哈德逊，离我现在住的地方不远。于是我给她打了电话。我没有立刻告诉她我是查尔斯顿人，只说我想就电台节目采访她。她说她很高兴。
A few days later, I received a polite note, banged out on an old standard typewriter. Let me read it here.
几天后，我收到了一封礼貌的信，是用一台老式打字机打出来的。让我读一下。
"Dear Mr. Hitt, I look forward to seeing you on Sunday. I am disabled now since a freak accident. The doctor said I would never walk again, but I am doing so quite well.
“亲爱的希特先生，我期待着周日与您见面。自从一场离奇的事故后，我现在残疾了。医生说我再也不能走路了，但我现在恢复得相当好。
Am in the middle of moving into a townhouse, which I'm buying. I have lived in this rundown old Dutch house for five years because it was the only place I could find where my dog would be welcome.
我正忙着搬进一栋我买下的联排别墅。过去五年我一直住在这栋破旧的荷兰式老房子里，因为那是唯一一个我可以找到愿意接纳我的狗的地方。
After 10 years, we have my husband home from the mental hospital. It is not easy as he hears voices and sometimes talks, shouts, and hollers all night. So many people do not understand what mental sickness can do to a family until it hits them."
十年了，我们终于把丈夫从精神病院接回了家。这不容易，因为他会听到声音，有时还会整夜说话、叫喊、咆哮。很多人在亲身经历之前，根本不理解精神疾病会对一个家庭造成什么影响。”
The letter is signed rather formally, "With all good wishes. Yours sincerely, Dawn Langley Simmons."
信的结尾非常正式地签着：“致以最美好的祝愿。您真诚的，道恩·兰利·西蒙斯。”
Coming up, Jack Hitt's visit with Dawn Langley Simmons. That's in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，是杰克·希特对道恩·兰利·西蒙斯的访问。请在国际公共广播电台节目继续之后收听。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. The deeper Jack Hitt delved into the mystery of Gordon Langley Hall, aka Dawn Langley Hall, aka Dawn Langley Simmons, the more questions opened up.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。杰克·希特对戈登·兰利·霍尔（又名道恩·兰利·霍尔，又名道恩·兰利·西蒙斯）的谜团挖掘得越深，打开的问题就越多。
Take, for example, this fairly straightforward clipping from the New York Daily News , November 21, 1968, page four. It announces that Gordon Langley Hall, biographer of Jackie Onassis and Mrs. Lyndon Johnson, has changed his sex. And then a little ways into this article, it goes to quote from the hospital that performed most of the early sex change operations that were ever performed in this country or anywhere. Quote, "In Baltimore, a Johns Hopkins spokesman said, in response to a query, 'Miss Hall was a patient. Miss Hall underwent surgery.' He would not comment further."
比如，来看看这篇1968年11月21日《纽约每日新闻》第四版上一篇相当直白的剪报。它宣布了杰基·奥纳西斯和林登·约翰逊夫人的传记作者戈登·兰利·霍尔已经改变了性别。在这篇文章的后段，它引用了医院的一段话，那家医院进行了当时国内乃至全球大多数早期变性手术。引述：“在巴尔的摩，约翰霍普金斯大学的一位发言人在回应查询时说：‘霍尔小姐曾是一位病人。霍尔小姐接受了手术。’他拒绝作进一步评论。”
When Jack Hitt finally met Dawn, even the nature of this surgery came into question. Our story continues.
当杰克·希特最终见到道恩时，甚至连这场手术的性质都受到了质疑。我们的故事继续。
On a rainy, cold morning I pulled up to her house. The only one with a bay window on the street, she had told me. The image I had was of a mansion, like in Charleston. But it turns out her house is near the train station, a vacant street with neglected warehouses. Even in the morning, a bar down the way was open. At her door, the brown paint was peeled and cracked. In the foyer it felt dank. The walls were missing chunks of plaster. A dead vacuum cleaner appeared chucked on a heap of trash.
在一个寒冷的雨天，我把车开到了她家门口。她说那是街上唯一有凸窗的房子。我原本想象的是像在查尔斯顿那样的豪宅。但结果发现她的房子靠近火车站，那是一条荒凉的街道，满是废弃的仓库。即使在早上，路边的一家酒吧也开着门。在她家门口，棕色的油漆剥落开裂。门厅里感觉很阴冷，墙上缺了几块灰泥。一个废弃的真空吸尘器看起来被扔在一堆垃圾上。
The wooden balustrade led up the stairs where Dawn appeared from a doorway. She was small, dressed in a red smock and purple leggings. Her grey hair was dyed red. It had three inches of white roots. She looked like an old lady, complete with dowager's hump. And then there were those piercing brown eyes that had not changed in 30 years. Friend or foe, they queried.
木质栏杆通向楼梯，道恩从门口出现了。她身材矮小，穿着红色的罩衫和紫色的打底裤。她的灰发被染成了红色，有三英寸的白色发根。她看起来像一位老妇人，还有老年驼背。然后是那双锐利的棕色眼睛，30年来没有变过。它们像是在询问，是敌还是友。
Good morning. Delighted, she said.
“早上好。很高兴见到你，”她说。
Inside her house, there were four dogs and five cats racing up and down the wide, last century floorboards. Most of the walls were scratched up. A slight aroma of ancient urine perfumed the air. A few antiques in need of some work were positioned along the walls, above which hung a gallery of photographs and paintings.
在她房子里，四条狗和五只猫在上一世纪遗留下来的宽大木地板上跑来跑去。大部分墙壁都被抓花了。空气中弥漫着淡淡的陈年尿味。几件需要修缮的古董靠墙摆放，上方挂着一系列照片和画作。
As I set up my equipment, a large black man appeared in a doorway in just his underpants. He quickly closed the saloon style swinging doors, and then leapt into a heap of blankets on a bed. From time to time, I would hear him softly snoring. Although I did not see him again, John-Paul's presence never left the room.
当我架设设备时，一个高大的黑人出现在门口，只穿着内裤。他迅速关上了酒吧式的摇摆门，然后跳进床上一堆毯子里。我不时能听到他轻微的打鼾声。虽然我没再见过他，但约翰-保罗的存在感始终没有离开过房间。
Dawn apologized for a hump, which was actually a stoop. She slumped in a chair to get comfortable, adjusted her dress, and began at the beginning.
道恩为她的驼背道歉，其实那是弯腰。她瘫坐在椅子上让自己舒服些，整理了一下衣服，从头开始讲述。
I was born in a country village in England with a country midwife. And when I was born, the clitoris was so small they couldn't tell if I was a little baby boy or a little girl. And the law in England was at that time-- it was a very cruel law, which incidentally was changed through my case. The law in England at that time was that, when in doubt, the child is just automatically registered as a boy, with dire results.
我出生在英国的一个乡村，是由一位乡村助产士接生的。我出生时，阴蒂太小了，他们分不清我是个男婴还是女婴。当时英国的法律——那是一条非常残酷的法律，顺便提一下，正是因为我的案子才得以修改。当时英国的法律规定，如果无法确定，孩子会自动登记为男孩，结果非常糟糕。
Now today, if that had happened, the baby is immediately taken to the hospital, and has just a little surgery, and everything is put right. In my case, it wasn't. And it was very difficult. I looked like a little girl. Then when menstruation started, it was irregular and that, but it was very frightening.
如果今天发生这种情况，婴儿会立即被送往医院，做个小手术，一切都会得到纠正。但在我的例子里，并没有。那非常困难。我看起来像个小女孩。后来月经初潮时，它是不规律的，那真的很可怕。
So here we are at the most fundamental fact of Dawn's life, and her version is totally different from what I had heard. That there was no sex change operation. That she was always a woman, forced to live as a man.
所以，这就是道恩生命中最根本的事实，而她的版本与我之前听到的完全不同。根本没有什么变性手术。她一直是一个女人，是被迫像男人一样生活。
Then she told me that she grew up with her father, who was, in her words, the factotum and chauffeur at writer Vita Sackville-West's famous estate known as Sissinghurst. Living there, Dawn sometimes saw Virginia Woolf and other literary visitors.
接着她告诉我，她是在她父亲身边长大的。用她的话说，她父亲是作家维塔·萨克维尔-韦斯特（Vita Sackville-West）著名的西辛赫斯特（Sissinghurst）庄园里的杂役兼司机。住在那里时，道恩（Dawn）有时会见到弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫（Virginia Woolf）和其他文学界访客。
Then, as the young Gordon, she moved to America to write for a Missouri newspaper. But for Dawn, every aspect of her life has a kind of gorgeousity. Every anecdote has a silent movie grand gesture to it, as if it should be punctuated with Greta Garbo sweeping into the room and striking a pose near a piano.
后来，作为年轻的戈登（Gordon），她搬到美国为一家密苏里州的报社写稿。但对道恩来说，她生活的方方面面都有一种华丽感。每一个轶事都带有默片时代那种宏大的姿态，仿佛就应该以葛丽泰·嘉宝（Greta Garbo）扫视全场并在钢琴旁摆好姿势作为注脚。
My first job was as a society editor in Nevada, Missouri. And it was played up in all the national press that I was the first male society editor in the state of Missouri. And all I can say is, oh, well, if only they knew.
我的第一份工作是在密苏里州内华达市担任社会版编辑。当时的全国媒体大肆渲染我是密苏里州第一位男性社会版编辑。我对此只能说，唉，要是他们早知道真相就好了。
When I first decided to explore the Dawn cycle, I wanted to discover the true story of her as a person, assuming it would be so much simpler than all the embroidered rumors I'd grown up with.
当我最初决定探索“道恩周期”时，我想要发掘她作为个人的真实故事，以为这会比我从小听到的那些添油加醋的传闻简单得多。
Back home, those tales were all about myth, voodoo, the evil eye, pigs. Instead, Dawn's version would turn out to be more fantastic than anything we Charlestonians had cooked up.
在老家，那些传闻全都是关于神话、巫毒、邪眼和猪。然而，道恩的版本最终却比我们这些查尔斯顿人编造出来的任何东西都要离奇。
One story, for example, featured the mafia, a vengeful ex-lover, two chihuahuas, hit men, a $1 million dollar lawsuit, and the Elvis-bashing biographer, Albert Goldman, who once mentioned Dawn in an Esquire article.
例如，其中一个故事涉及黑手党、一个心怀怨恨的前任情人、两只吉娃娃、职业杀手、一笔100万美元的诉讼，还有那位诋毁猫王的传记作家阿尔伯特·戈德曼（Albert Goldman），他曾在《时尚先生》的一篇文章中提到过道恩。
And he said that Dawn Langley Simmons had two Chihuahuas for bridesmaids at her wedding. Well, I didn't have two Chihuahuas as bridesmaids at my wedding. My little maid was married in the house, and she looked after the two Chihuahuas. And she brought them down to her wedding on a cushion. And this was the story.
他说，道恩·兰利·西蒙斯（Dawn Langley Simmons）结婚时，有两只吉娃娃做伴娘。嗯，我结婚时根本没有两只吉娃娃做伴娘。我的小女仆是在家里结婚的，她照顾那两只吉娃娃。她把它们放在垫子上带到了自己的婚礼上。这就是事实。
So I called Dena Crane, who was my media agent. And I said, Dena, you call that Albert Goldman, and you tell him I'm suing him for $1 million if he doesn't print a retraction. I did not have two chihuahuas as bridesmaids at my wedding.
所以我给我的媒体代理人迪娜·克雷恩（Dena Crane）打了电话。我说：“迪娜，你给那个阿尔伯特·戈德曼打电话，告诉他，如果他不刊登更正启事，我就要起诉他赔偿100万美元。我结婚时根本没有让两只吉娃娃当伴娘。”
And so he called up, in turn, Dena. He said, you tell Dawn that if she doesn't sue me, I'll tell her who tried to have her killed in Charleston. And we'll come to that in just a moment. And he did. He was investigating the role that the mafia had played in the drug trafficking. They used the inland waterways and so forth, and the lonely plantations and so forth. And he was told this story in a bar. And apparently, this group of old Charleston society people, led by this former lover, had put a contract on my life.
于是他反过来给迪娜打了电话。他说：“你告诉道恩，如果她不起诉我，我就告诉她当年是谁在查尔斯顿试图暗杀她。”我们待会儿再谈这个。他确实这么说了。他当时正在调查黑手党在毒品走私中扮演的角色。他们利用内陆水道之类的路线，还有那些偏僻的种植园等等。他在一家酒吧里听到了这个故事。显然，这群老派的查尔斯顿社会名流，在那个前情人的带领下，对我发出了追杀令。
And of course, that night I was alone in the house and Natasha was then been born, my daughter. And I heard a crash upstairs. And I thought the baby had fallen out of her cot. I ran upstairs, and there was a man standing over her wearing a ski mask-- a white man-- holding a knife over the baby. He broke my nose. He crippled this arm, which has never been-- I've been able to use it properly since. And broke my big toe, beating me up. And it was a rape thing. And then he threw me off the porch. The porch was three stories up.
当然，那天晚上我独自在家，那时娜塔莎（Natasha）已经出生了，那是我的女儿。我听到楼上传来一声巨响。我以为婴儿从婴儿床里掉下来了。我跑上楼，有个男人正站在她上方，戴着滑雪面罩——一个白人——手里拿着一把刀对着婴儿。他打断了我的鼻子。他弄残了这只手臂，从那以后我就再也没能正常使用过它。还打断了我的大脚趾，把我打了一顿。那是一次强奸未遂。然后他把我从门廊扔了下去。门廊有三层楼高。
I was fortunate to land on a lump of sand. And covered with blood, I crawled in the house. And that actually happened. And I was very glad to know. But now going back to John---
幸运的是，我掉在一堆沙子上。我浑身是血地爬回了屋里。那确实发生了。我很高兴能知道真相。但现在回到约翰身上——
I have to say how strange it was to be sitting there talking to Dawn Langley Hall. All my life, she was a distant figure. Even when she was the man or lady walking across the street, she was mainly myth. Seeing her in her house was like sitting next to Hera, wife of Zeus.
我不得不说，坐在那里与道恩·兰利·霍尔（Dawn Langley Hall）交谈是多么奇妙的感觉。我的一生中，她一直是一个遥不可及的人物。即使当她是那个走在街上的男人或女人时，她主要也只是个神话。在她的房子里见到她，就像坐在宙斯的妻子赫拉身边一样。
And the odd thing about a radio interview is you have to hold the microphone right in a person's face. I was probably 12 inches from her, a weird zone of intimacy. I could see her pores. I could see the few old lady hairs above her lip, the lines in her pancake makeup.
电台采访最奇怪的一点是，你必须把麦克风直接凑到对方脸上。我离她可能只有12英寸远，一种诡异的亲密地带。我能看到她的毛孔。我能看到她唇上那几根老太太的汗毛，还有她粉底下的细纹。
I set off on this journey to separate Dawn, the person, from all the stories. And while I was sitting there, talking to her, in her house, I realized, I have always wanted to just look at her, the way a 10-year-old boy wants to look at anything new and different, like a car wreck, or people naked through a window, or a dead animal, or a good house fire, or a transsexual.
我踏上这段旅程是为了将道恩这个“人”从所有的故事中剥离出来。当我坐在她家里的那间屋子里和她交谈时，我意识到，我一直以来只是想注视着她，就像一个10岁的男孩想要注视任何新鲜和不同的东西一样——比如车祸现场，透过窗户偷看裸体的人，或者死去的动物，一场大火，或者一个变性人。
When I came home that night, my wife and I sat down to exchange accounts of our day. Both of us had amazing stories to tell. Lisa is a med student. And she told me that in the hospital that very day she had assisted with an operation on a newborn girl. The affliction is called virilization, and the symptoms are an adrenal abnormality that causes the clitoris to expand to the size of the tip of your thumb and look like a penis. At the same time, the vaginal lips are fused and swell into what looks like a scrotum.
那天晚上回家后，我和妻子坐下来交换我们一天的经历。我们俩都有令人惊叹的故事要讲。丽莎是名医学生。她告诉我，就在那天，她在医院协助进行了一台新生女婴的手术。这种病症被称为“男性化”，症状是一种肾上腺异常，导致阴蒂膨胀到拇指尖那么大，看起来像阴茎。与此同时，阴唇融合在一起，肿胀得看起来像阴囊。
These days it is easily corrected with a simple operation. So what if it were all true? That Dawn was born a girl, and wrongly sexed, as she called it. So that her life, her awakening, her metamorphosis, even her child, all of that could be biologically possible.
这些天来，通过一个小手术就能轻易矫正。如果这一切都是真的呢？道恩出生时是个女孩，正如她所说的“性别认错”。这样一来，她的一生、她的觉醒、她的蜕变，甚至她的孩子，这一切在生物学上都是可能的。
Imagine if the hysteria and outrage that generated the entire Dawn epic cycle just boiled down to all of us reacting like a pack of enraged orangutans at something unfamiliar. Imagine it.
试想一下，如果引发整个“道恩史诗周期”的歇斯底里和愤怒，归根结底只是我们所有人像一群暴怒的红毛猩猩一样，对陌生的事物做出反应。试想一下。
But I'll be honest, I've told myself these stories so many times, I can not imagine it. But Dawn can.
但我老实说，这些故事我对自己讲过太多次了，我无法想象。但道恩可以。
I had a recurring dream in which I saw an old fashioned glass hearse with plumes turning to go into the cemetery. And in the casket was Gordon. And that was a recurring dream. And of course, I grew up at Sissinghurst. And Virginia Woolf had written Orlando , the wonderful story about her friend and lover Vita Sackville-West. How over the years Orlando had turned from a beautiful young man into a beautiful woman. And so I felt in my heart that I was the living Orlando.
我曾做一个重复的梦，梦见一辆老式的玻璃灵车，上面插着羽毛，转弯进入墓地。棺材里装的是戈登。那是一个重复的梦。当然，我在西辛赫斯特长大。弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫写过《奥兰多》，那部关于她朋友兼情人维塔·萨克维尔-韦斯特的精彩故事。书中讲述了奥兰多多年来如何从一个美丽的年轻男子变成了美丽的女人。所以我在内心深处感到，我就是活着的奥兰多。
So here's Dawn Langley Hall, the living Orlando. And yet, all the outlandish stories of her life are contained within an unexpected concern for propriety. She married once in 1969. And long after the publicity faded, she stood with her man through madness and poverty. She never divorced or remarried, a claim that Newt Gingrich and Rush Limbaugh can not make.
所以，这就是道恩·兰利·霍尔，活着的奥兰多。然而，她生活中所有荒诞的故事都包含在一种对礼仪的出人意料的关注中。她在1969年结过一次婚。在舆论平息很久之后，她依然在疯狂和贫困中与她的男人相守。她从未离婚或再婚，这是纽特·金里奇（Newt Gingrich）和拉什·林博（Rush Limbaugh）无法宣称的。
She dotes on her daughter Natasha and reports to her pew every Sunday at Christ Episcopal Church in Hudson with her two grandchildren in tow.
她非常疼爱女儿娜塔莎，每周日都会带着她的两个孙子去哈德逊（Hudson）的基督圣公会教堂做礼拜。
When you look at the pictures of Gordon, he was dapper, always in a coat and tie, very sharp looking. Very hip in a way. You know, young writer guy. And yet, Dawn turns into this rather, almost frumpy wife-like woman. I mean, what's that about?
当你看着戈登的照片时，他衣冠楚楚，总是穿着西装打着领带，看起来非常干练。在某种程度上很时髦。你知道，就是一个年轻的男作家。然而，道恩却变成了一个相当、几乎是有些邋遢的家庭主妇。我是说，这是怎么回事？
Well, I wanted to be a wife more than anything. You're absolutely correct. Dawn was proper, the same as her family in England, the same as Charleston society. Those are the people that I identify with. I have always put duty first, because that was how I was brought up.
嗯，我最想做的就是成为一名妻子。你是完全正确的。道恩很讲究礼仪，就像她在英国的家人一样，就像查尔斯顿的社会名流一样。那些是我认同的人。我一直把责任放在第一位，因为我就是那样长大的。
You know, when I was reading your book, you mentioned that your father was a mechanic and your mother-- I guess this was an illegitimate birth, right? She was 15. She was 15 when you were born. And yet, given the lineage on both sides, there were all these aristocrats. Some of them English, some of them Spanish, and so forth and so on. It's quite a list of contessas and various countesses and so forth.
你知道，当我在读你的书时，你提到你父亲是个机械师，而你母亲——我想这是私生子，对吧？她生你的时候才15岁。然而，从双方的血统来看，那里有那么多的贵族。有些是英国的，有些是西班牙的，等等等等。这真是一份很长的伯爵夫人和各种女伯爵名单。
You know, when I was reading that I kept thinking, it felt like a Dickens novel.
你知道，当我读到这里时，我一直觉得，这感觉就像一部狄更斯的小说。
Absolutely.
完全正确。
I kept expecting at some point, someone's going to come along and discover who Dawn is.
我一直期待着在某个时刻，会有人出现并揭开道恩的身世。
Yeah, absolutely.
是的，绝对是。
And everything will be OK. Is that what's happened?
然后一切都会好起来的。事情是这样发展的吗？
This came out with-- another fellow author in England wrote and said, I always knew you came from good stock. And it was one of those things. It has been a long road. Everything has just gone full circle.
这事被揭开了——英国的另一位作家写道，我一直知道你出身名门。就是那种事情之一。这是一段漫长的旅程。一切都兜了一圈回到了原点。
I've done the mansion bit. I've done the debutante bit. I've been everything. Now, give me a little peace. Let me be me.
我经历过豪门生活，也经历过名媛社交。我什么都当过。现在，给我一点平静吧。让我做我自己。
Violating any boundary is always difficult. But typically when one does cross forbidden lines-- interracial or interreligious marriage, or announcing that one is gay, or changing one's sex-- at least there is a community waiting for you on the other side. But Dawn has crossed so many borders at once that she has slipped into a country where she is the only citizen. She is poor, her husband is schizophrenic, her life is fairly harsh, her books overcompensatingly sentimental. She speaks a unique language, a kind of Gothic romance.
违反任何界限总是困难的。但通常当你跨越禁忌的界限时——比如跨种族或跨宗教的婚姻，或者宣布自己是同性恋，或者改变性别——至少在另一边有一个社区在等待着你。但道恩一次跨越了太多的界限，以至于她滑入了一个只有她一个公民的国家。她很穷，丈夫患有精神分裂症，她的生活相当艰辛，她的书写得过度感伤。她说着一种独特的语言，一种哥特式浪漫。
Even as I sat in her living room-- slightly aromatic from her dogs, her once beautiful antiques aged into ruin-- it was difficult not to feel a real respect for her for roughing it out. No one pressured her into the life she chose. She dwells in her own private Charleston. Now a bona fide dowager, ready to serve tea, hospitable, even brave, but alone.
即使当我坐在她的客厅里时——房间里飘着她狗的味道，她曾经美丽的古董已沦为废墟——我很难不为她的坚韧而感到真正的尊重。没有人强迫她选择这样的生活。她居住在属于她自己的私人查尔斯顿。现在，她是一位名副其实的孀妇，准备端茶倒水，热情好客，甚至勇敢，但却是孤独的。
When I asked her at the end of our interview if she remembered a little red-headed boy who stared into her gates, she allowed that she did. She said she had quite fond memories of the family down the street. She chose not to mention the obvious, that my father refused to publish her story in the local paper. Instead, like a true Charlestonian, she behaved as if she had stumbled upon an old acquaintance and was simply delighted to be back in touch.
在采访结束时，当我问她是否还记得那个盯着她家大门看的小红发男孩时，她承认她记得。她说她对街那家人有相当美好的回忆。她选择不提显而易见的事实，即我父亲拒绝在当地报纸上发表她的故事。相反，像一个真正的查尔斯顿人一样，她表现得好像是偶然遇到了一个老相识，并为能重新联系上而感到高兴。
Then, as every Charlestonian I know, including myself, would do, she changed the subject to something more comfortable.
然后，正如我认识的每一位查尔斯顿人（包括我自己）都会做的那样，她把话题转移到了更轻松的事情上。
A few days later, I received another note that began--
几天后，我收到了另一张便条，开头写着——
"Dear Jack, as you are my red-haired boy at the gate, I think I should call you Jack and not Mr. Hitt." She said that she had bought her new house, a modest two-story place on Hudson's Main Street. It has some age to it, and she hopes to fix it up. As is the custom in England, she wants to give the house a name. She's pretty much set on using the title of a book by her old mentor, Vita Sackville-West. She wants to call her new house All Passion Spent question mark. She invites me to come visit. And then the letter ends casually, "Yours sincerely, Dawn."
“亲爱的杰克，既然你是那个在门外看我的红发男孩，我想我应该叫你杰克，而不是希特先生（Mr. Hitt）。”她说她买了新房子，是哈德逊主街上一处不起眼的两层小楼。房子有点年代了，她希望能修缮一下。按照英国的习俗，她想给房子起个名字。她差不多确定要用她导师维塔·萨克维尔-韦斯特的一本书名。她想把她的新房子叫《激情已逝》（All Passion Spent）。她邀请我去参观。然后信随口结尾道：“你真诚的，道恩。”
[MUSIC - "LA VIE EN ROSE," MARLENE DIETRICH]
[音乐 - “玫瑰人生”，玛琳·黛德丽]
Act two, Dawn of a New Era. Well, up until this point in our program, you've been listening to a story that first aired on our show two and a half years ago. Since then, a lot has happened. Dawn, incredibly, has moved back to Charleston at the urging of her daughter. She now lives in an otherwise all black neighborhood in a rundown old house. She meets with old women, basically has managed to get the life that she wanted as a dowager in Charleston.
第二幕，新时代的黎明。嗯，直到节目现在的部分，你们听到的都是我们节目在两年半前首次播出的故事。从那以后，发生了很多事。令人难以置信的是，在女儿的强烈要求下，道恩搬回了查尔斯顿。她现在住在一个基本上全黑人的社区里，在一栋破旧的老房子里。她会见老妇人，基本上设法过上了她想要的查尔斯顿孀妇的生活。
Dawn's schizophrenic husband, John-Paul, now lives in a mental institution. And Jack Hitt has stayed in touch, gotten many letters that begin, "My dear red-haired boy." Just this month, he published a story in the magazine GQ about what he's learned since his original report for our program. He agreed to do a little update with us.
道恩患有精神分裂症的丈夫约翰-保罗现在住在一所精神病院里。杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）一直与她保持联系，收到了许多以“我亲爱的红发男孩”开头的信。就在这个月，他在《智族》（GQ）杂志上发表了一篇文章，讲述了他自最初为我们的节目报道以来的所见所闻。他同意为我们做一点更新。
After I did the initial interview with her two and half years ago for This American Life , she and I maintained a correspondence. She wrote me pretty much every other day.
在我两年前半为《美国生活》（This American Life）对她进行首次采访后，我和她保持了通信。她几乎每隔一天就给我写信。
And each of these is a little typewritten letter?
每一封都是打字机打的小信件吗？
Often a letter, but more often than not, it's an envelope containing clips from the local newspaper that are, in some way, indicative of subjects that she thinks she and I share.
通常是信，但更多时候，是一个信封，里面装满了当地报纸的剪报，这些剪报在某种程度上暗示了她认为我们共同关心的话题。
Like what kind of thing?
比如什么样的内容？
They often have almost metaphysical significance. For example, one story was about finding some sunken treasure just outside the harbor. And I couldn't quite figure out what the meaning of it was until I suddenly just sort of stared at the headline where it said, "Old Charleston Continues to Yield its Secrets." And it just suddenly dawned on me that maybe that was the only reason she sent me the piece--
它们往往具有某种形而上学的意义。例如，有一篇报道是关于在港口外发现了一些沉船宝藏。我一直没弄明白它的含义，直到我突然盯着标题看，上面写着：“老查尔斯顿继续出产它的秘密。”我突然意识到，这可能就是她寄给我这篇文章的唯一原因——
Wow.
哇。
--was that headline.
——就是那个标题。
It's like each one is like a little hieroglyph.
就像每一封信都是一个小象形文字。
Right. They're rather cryptic. I sometimes don't quite understand why I'm getting them. But anyway, Dawn and I very much stayed in contact. We've seen each other a bunch of times since then. I've met her daughter. I've met her two grandchildren.
没错。它们相当隐晦。我有时不太明白为什么要收到这些。但无论如何，道恩和我确实保持了联系。自那以后，我们见过很多次。我见过她的女儿。我见过她的两个孙子。
When you followed your story for us, when you did you story for us two and a half years ago, when the story ended, you weren't exactly sure what to believe about her story. And since then, with all this contact with her and meeting her family and spending more time with her, you actually now know what you believe to be the truth.
当你为我们跟进你的故事时，当你在两年半前为我们做节目时，故事结束时，你并不确定该如何看待她的故事。从那以后，随着与她的所有接触，见到她的家人并花更多时间与她相处，你现在确实知道你所认为的真相是什么了。
Well, I do. I do believe that she was born a woman with a defect. You know, when I first interviewed her for the program, when I came home, you remember, my wife had just participated in this odd little surgery at the local hospital for this problem called virilization. And subsequent reporting with a pediatrician named Anjali Jain, taught me that this condition is called hyperplasia. And that, in fact, it's common enough that every child at birth in this country is screened for it now.
嗯，我知道。我确实相信她出生时就是一个有生理缺陷的女人。你知道，当我第一次为节目采访她时，当我回到家，你还记得，我妻子刚刚在当地医院参加了一台针对这种叫“男性化”问题的奇怪小手术。后来，在儿科医生安贾莉·贾恩（Anjali Jain）的报道中，我了解到这种状况被称为“增生”。事实上，它很普遍，现在这个国家的每个孩子出生时都会接受筛查。
Her description of what she went through, every detail, the sort of biannual menses and lack of breast development and all the various afflictions she talks about through her adolescence and into her adulthood were described exactly that way by Dr. Jain when I interviewed her.
她描述的所经历的一切，每一个细节，那种每半年一次的月经，乳房发育不良，以及她在青春期到成年后所谈论的所有各种折磨，在采访贾恩医生时，她描述的方式完全一致。
Plus the fact I interviewed her daughter at length. I found when Dawn moved back to Charleston, the daughter was there. She's working two jobs. And I just asked her outright. There are people who think that your mother is not a woman. And she explained that she knew in a way that a daughter would know that she was a woman.
另外，我还详细采访了她的女儿。我发现当道恩搬回查尔斯顿的时候，女儿也在那里。她在做两份工作。我就直接问她了。有些人认为你母亲不是女人。她解释说，她以女儿所知道的方式知道她是女人。
Well, she said she took care of her, right?
嗯，她说她照顾她，对吧？
She takes care of her, yeah. I mean, Dawn has had a rough time physically for decades. And the daughter has taken care of her in the way that a nurse would take care of her.
她确实照顾她。我的意思是，道恩几十年来在身体上一直过得很艰难。女儿像护士照顾病人一样照顾她。
One of the things that you mentioned in the story is this story that Dawn tells about an attempt on her life and Albert Goldman. And in your original story two and a half years ago, you sort of presented it as like look at all the tales around this woman. Do you have an opinion now about whether, in fact, those things happened?
你在故事中提到的事情之一是道恩讲述的关于她生命受到威胁和阿尔伯特·戈德曼的故事。在两年半前你最初的故事中，你把它描述为，看看这个女人周围所有的传闻。你现在有没有什么看法，那些事情到底有没有发生？
To listen to Dawn tell a story, I mean I think she mythologizes herself as much as we did. But to a different end. I mean, I was amazed that every story she had to tell had very similar themes to them, of a lost aristocrat being denied her due. And in some way, she is, in real life-- I mean in her childhood, she was the illegitimate offspring of Vita Sackville-West's chauffeur. He is shunned by all of these people. She always sees herself as being kept out of her real life, of the life that she was supposed to have lived. And it's true. And those themes never escape her telling of almost any story.
听道恩讲故事，我的意思是，我认为她像我们一样把自己神话化了。但目的不同。我是说，我很惊讶她讲的每一个故事都有非常相似的主题，都是关于一个被剥夺了应有权利的失落贵族。从某种程度上说，在现实生活中，她是——我是说在她童年时期，她是维塔·萨克维尔-韦斯特司机的私生女。他被所有人排斥。她总是认为自己被挡在了真实生活之外，被挡在她本该过上的生活之外。这是真的。这些主题从未离开过她所讲述的任何故事。
And so when she tells a story of someone breaking into her house and trying to harm her, and beating her, or whatever, I think there is a core of truth to these stories. But I think it's very complicated. I think she has a narrative way of telling her stories that make them seem, I think, preposterous to many people.
所以当她讲述有人闯入她家试图伤害她，并殴打她之类的故事时，我认为这些故事有核心事实。但我认为这非常复杂。我认为她有一种叙事方式来讲述她的故事，让这些故事在许多人看来显得荒谬。
And that gets to one of the things about this story, which is so tragic. There are the stories that we tell ourselves about who we are and then there are the stories that other people say about who we are. And if those two things don't match up in large part, you're in for trouble. And that's what happened to her. The story that she believed about herself was so radically different from the story that the world believed about her.
这就触及了这个故事的一点，那是非常悲剧的。有些是我们对自己身份的描述，还有些是别人对我们身份的描述。如果这两者在很大程度上不匹配，你就会有麻烦。这就是发生在她身上的事。她对自己所信奉的故事与世界对她所信奉的故事有着本质上的不同。
Right. And realize that the world, from the very beginning, was forcing her to live a myth that she was a man. When, in fact, on some level she was a woman.
没错。而且你要意识到，世界从一开始就强迫她活在一个“她是男人”的神话中。而事实上，她在某种程度上是一个女人。
In the GQ piece, there is an anecdote I ran across. She kept mentioning Carson McCullers, so I went and looked up Carson McCullers' biography. And it turns out that Gordon is mentioned in the book. And it's a rather eerie scene. There's only one mention of Gordon in the entire biography of Carson McCullers.
在《智族》的文章中，有一个我偶然发现的轶事。她一直提到卡森·麦卡勒斯（Carson McCullers），所以我去查了卡森·麦卡勒斯的传记。结果发现戈登在书中被提到了。这是一个相当离奇的场景。在卡森·麦卡勒斯的整部传记中，只有一次提到了戈登。
And McCullers comes to Charleston at some point in the early '60s, when Gordon was still very much a guy. And Gordon, at that point, is a well known novelist and has Carson McCullers in for dinner. This is right down the street. This is when I'm 10 years old. And so Carson is an older person at that point, and at the end of the party-- hasn't said much the entire evening, but at the end of the party asks Gordon to come sit in a chair in the corner of the room. And they talk very briefly.
麦卡勒斯在60年代初的某个时候来到查尔斯顿，那时戈登还是个地道的男人。戈登当时是一位著名的小说家，邀请卡森·麦卡勒斯共进晚餐。就在街角。那时我才10岁。所以卡森当时年纪较大，在派对结束时——整个晚上没说什么话，但在派对结束时，她请戈登到房间角落的椅子上坐下。他们简单地交谈了一下。
And McCullers' description of this moment is that Gordon sort of talks on and on for a few minutes about this and that. And finally, McCullers stops him and touches him on the knee or something and says, "You're really a little girl, aren't you?" And Gordon just sort of nods enigmatically.
麦卡勒斯对这一刻的描述是，戈登在那几分钟里喋喋不休地谈论着各种事情。最后，麦卡勒斯打断了他，摸了摸他的膝盖之类的，说：“你其实是个小女孩，对吧？”戈登只是神秘地点了点头。
Jack Hitt is the author of innumerable magazine articles and numerable books. He writes about Dawn in the October 1998 issue of GQ.
杰克·希特是无数杂志文章和书籍的作者。他在1998年10月号的《智族》杂志上撰写了关于道恩的文章。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel, Peter Clowney, Dolores Wilber and Julie Snyder. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. Production help from Emi Takahara and [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. Music help today from Steve Cushing and [UNINTELLIGIBLE] Rattles.
嗯，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我本人制作，还有阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）、多洛雷斯·威尔伯（Dolores Wilber）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特、玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。制作协助：艾米·高原（Emi Takahara）和[听不清]。音乐协助：史蒂夫·库兴（Steve Cushing）和[听不清]·拉特尔斯（Rattles）。
If you'd like to buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Or you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at our website, www.thislife.org. That's thislife, one word, no space.
如果你想购买本节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，号码是312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected] 。或者你知道你可以在我们的网站 www.thislife.org 上免费收听我们的大部分节目。那是“thislife”，一个词，中间没有空格。
Thanks to Elizabeth Meister who runs the site.
感谢负责网站运营的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。
This American Life if distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》节目由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who attributes our success as a radio program entirely to--
WBEZ电台的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他将我们作为一档广播节目的成功完全归功于——
Voodoo, the evil eye, pigs.
巫毒、邪眼、猪。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），下周将带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。